it is January 16 2023 and you're
watching the code report Tailwind is the
worst way to do CSS except for all the
other ways that have been tried an epic
war erupted yesterday after somebody had
the audacity to post a Tailwind snippet
on Twitter the Allied Tailwind Alliance
defended this code while the unified CSS
fundamentalists said horrible
dehumanizing things about it like it's
not even real CSS as a result many
insecure nerds suffered slightly hurt
feelings from hearing mild criticisms
about technology choices that their
clients will never care about it was
truly horrific I decided to run a poll
to see where you guys fall and although
most have never tried it 4 out of five
people that have tried Tailwind love it
still though it has its trade-offs and
may not be a good fit for every project
in this video I want to explain the
problems Tailwind solves because it's
obvious that many people don't even
understand them yet still have no
problem hating on a free and open source
tool publicly I personally joined the
Tailwind Colt a couple years ago after
refusing to drink the Kool-Aid for quite
a while in my experience it's a tool
like typescript or svelte that makes it
really hard to go back to the thing you
were using before because it saves a ton
of time time and becoming a productive
developer is all about using your time
wisely the first problem with CSS is
co-location the standard practice for
the last 20 years has been to separate
your CSS from the markup to provide a
good separation of concerns and doing
otherwise means you go to hell as
programmers we know the hardest part of
the job is naming things and this
practice requires you to come up with a
lot of arbitrary names that are often
pointless a few weeks later when you
come back to modify this code it becomes
difficult to figure out which Styles
actually apply to each element because
you've totally forgotten what these
class names do and you might have used
these class names in multiple places so
if you try to change it it could break
unexpected parts of the UI Tailwind
addresses this problem by giving you
standard utility classes that are
co-located in the HTML this results in
disgusting bloated HTML that looks like
Blasphemous inline Styles at first
glance and that's a very valid criticism
and likely the main turn off for people
when they first look into using Tailwind
however the benefit is that you don't
have all these arbitrary class names
anymore and know exactly which Styles
apply to it and that just clears a ton
of mental overhead from your plate you
can make modifications safely without
breaking other parts of the app also
here's a little Pro tip if you're using
tailwind and hate the way your HTML
looks the inline fold vs code extension
can automatically minimize it for you
problem number two is that CSS is for
Bose remember everything in Tailwind is
just CSS hover over any class to view
the actual CSS code what's cool about it
though is that it uses clever naming
conventions like inset 0 to do something
in one line of code that would take six
lines of CSS because it combines
properties and values together I would
estimate that Tailwind results in
approximately one-third the total amount
of code that you would have with vanilla
CSS and the best type of code is the
code you never have to write however a
valid criticism of this approach is that
you have to learn an abstraction on top
of CSS which is not ideal it's always
best to use the platform natively but
the web platform is often cruel and
vengeful Now problem three is that CSS
gives you too much control over the UI
while Frameworks like bootstrap are too
difficult to customize Tailwind Falls
right in the middle of these giving you
a standard set of constraints to make
sure the UI looks good but tends to be
much easier to custom to accommodate any
design like when you build a bootstrap
app it always tends to look like a
bootstrap app with Tailwind is not so
obvious now the final problem I want to
talk about is zombie Styles we have a
tendency to write styles that never
actually get used and just blow the CSS
bundle Tailwind will automatically Purge
all unused styles to kill the Zombies
and remove this dead code that's pretty
cool but the drawback is that Tailwind
is a pretty heavy-handed approach it
takes like five steps to set up to
install the Tailwind CLI post CSS and
the vs code extension for that reason I
only use it on big projects for smaller
demos I've been using Pico CSS which can
make things look good with zero effort
thanks to its classless approach as you
can see there are many pros and cons to
a library like Tailwind ultimately
here's a good rule you can go by if you
like Tailwind use it if you don't like
Tailwind don't use it nobody cares
literally nobody cares about your
technology choices except you this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one